make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
is a man not entitled to take a break
from creating comic book videos for the
youtubes hello everyone
uh I have been gone for a week and it
seems like everybody is panicking like I
am dead no I am not dead I need a break
from doing this just like everybody else
and so I took my break for a week and we
are back to making videos and in this
video we are covering this story of
where Dormammu becomes The Herald of
Galactus almost a dr. strange and it's
actually amazing so here's a funny thing
when it comes to Doctor Strange as a cup
of a character for the average person it
usually seems like it's not worth the
price of admission right we're just kind
of like you know and I'll go do
something else instead it really seems
to feel like that like when it when it
cut because the Doctor Strange line of
comics really are for just a particular
kind of comic book fan now if you like
magic and mysticism of course it's for
you but if you're not a huge fan of that
you don't really want to have a whole
lot to do with it and that's kind of one
of the things that that Mark Waid sort
of hits on to a degree right like he
picks up this story and he's just kind
of like he's he has dr. strange sort of
musing to himself right and it's just
kind of like I've pretty much done
everything and so I'm bored now because
in reality that's the nature of Doctor
Strange comics right he's also he's one
of these weird characters he's the
master of the mystic arts and it's kind
of like I'm I know the most about magic
and you know than anybody else in the
knee in the universe but it's
interesting because the question he kind
of asks here is like is there no real
adventure left anymore like is it really
nothing for me to do like is this this
is kind of it like I'm just gonna be
sitting in the house watching in the
view and waiting for something to happen
and then he suddenly met by the arrival
of a guy named Zola's now here's the
cool thing
Zola's is a guy who cultural plan of the
Galactus is basically visited right like
he's part of a group called the Xerox
the Sur axioms and and the result is
that Galactus is literally going to
consume their world and so what his
people ended up doing was that as a mage
himself they basically took all of their
energies dumped it into him and the
result is that he's been sent here now
because when they scan through the mind
of Galactus to figure out what his
weakness was the only thing they could
find was Earth now this is why things
were interesting because olá shows up
here believing that Earth has someone
powerful enough to defeat Galactus and
they do I mean you got the molecule man
Owen Reese
you've got Franklin Richards who's
really more a kinder Galactus like
they're really more counterparts now the
you know in these days then they are
like you know one be more powerful the
other oh I guess the future version of
Franklin is basically like a counterpart
to Galactus but still like as we know as
read are the reason why Galactus sees
earth as a weakness is because of like
the totality of the heroes on it and
that's what you would need like you
would literally need like all the heroes
on earth to ban together fly to the
other side of the universe and like
defeat Galactus right but like they're
not going to because it's just the
natural role of Galactus and that's what
Zola's doesn't get is literally he just
kind of starts like getting into this
fight with Doctor Strange and of course
basically starts using his abilities to
like absorb magical energy to like
absorb all of doctor Strange's
duplicates into himself is really one of
these things worse like every step that
dr. strange takes this guy is powerful
enough to overcome and of course that
leads into him discovering like the
various books of dr. stranger than
absorbing all their knowledge now I want
to talk about this for a second when it
comes to magic and Marvel Comics there
was the way that things used to be and
then there's essentially kind of like
the way things are now right so the way
things used to be is that you had
essentially just like ambient energy out
there anybody who - who has a power
that's happened to like reality-warping
is harnessing the fundamental energies
of the universe is basically what it is
right so like if if the universe is clay
then they're essentially like tapping
into and manipulating that clay is
literally what they're doing when it
comes to like telepathy it's tapping
into the ambient energies basically
tapping in the ability to access the
astral plane more or less you know
access the realm where like thoughts go
to you as they pass from one location to
the next and then in turn you know
harness those thoughts to do whatever it
is that you want to do control them wipe
them out of somebody's head whatever the
case is
then there's the way that they exist now
right so like magic was it was just kind
of energy that was there and you could
manipulate it in Ultimates volume 2
issue number 100 by Al Ewing what he
said was that magic actually never used
to exist it wasn't until the varies you
know the multiverse was destroyed and
recreated destroyed and recreated when
it was destroyed and remade for the
fifth time did that version of eternity
had basically like brought magic into
the main Marvel Universe and said okay
magic is here now and people can use it
of course that multiverse was destroyed
and recreated again but the fact remains
like that's what magic started being
brought in and people had the ability to
access it so we know like of all the
different versions of the multiverse
that have ever existed there was never a
dr. strange until you got to the fifth
version again it's a little bit of a
little bit of a historical thing there
but the fact remains that what you have
here in this day and age is essentially
just like a wide array of different
people tapping into a wide array of
different powers now that was always the
case but how many somebody come along
who's more
dr. strange really highlights two things
one that of course there are people out
there who can use magic in a more adept
way than dr. strange and two dr. strange
is the sorcerer supreme in name only now
that's the indication that's put off
here that's the the basis behind like
what's being told because basically the
skies can let you have all these forms
of magical energy here like you have all
these things that you could use why
don't you just use them all now what
this does is it kind of moves into the
second part of that discussion that says
okay the difference here is that we're
doctor strage could absorb all these
forms of energy into himself all these
magical principles and then use them for
his own ends who knows what kind of
chaos would would erupt because of it
and so that's the the true nature of dr.
strange yes he could acquire absolute
power is it a good idea no now again
this kind of flies in the face of a lot
of stories we've seen before right like
dr. strange basically go into centres
market and then bartering 100% of his
soul from 100% of his power or at least
trying but we only know that well at
least we do know dr. strange only does
that in like the most extreme
circumstances right like the Beyonder
comes back and wants to attack earth
okay well then he'll do whatever he
needs to do in order to make that happen
but under a normal circumstance you
can't do that at the same time it's also
Zola's not really understanding the
nature of Galactus it's his role in the
cosmos right I mean it's just one of
those sakes if Galactus comes rolling up
on your place and it's gonna start like
consuming your entire planet sorry about
your luck that's just the way it goes
nice knowing you're like this it's
basically you know just like flee while
you can but it's the role of Galactus
he's a fundamental portal a part of the
universe and so again like we know that
from a wide array of different stories
but of course Zola's doesn't there so
basically channeling all these magical
energies he literally opens a portal in
the main Marvel Universe and whisks
galactose away to like the depths of the
mystic realms what this means is
Galactus is now in the realm of like
Dormammu and he's in the realm of like
nightmare he's in the realm of like all
these basic mystically of these these
mystical forces that are out there and
there's no guess as to what like there's
no telling what in the world is gonna
happen and that's what Doctor Strange
kind of freaks out about right like like
Galactus is a being of pure science
right like he serves a purpose it is
I am a being who travels around the
cosmos and I serve two purposes the
first is that I consume planets that can
sustain life sustaining energy so that
the Celestials cannot plant their eggs
and like every single planet across the
cosmos and overrun the universe and I
also do this because I'm a gate keeper
right if I die
Abraxas comes out and Abraxas will
basically wipe
the entire multiverse those you guys
who'd ever who don't know about Abraxas
he's essentially just like the like the
representation of the multiverse is
destruction right like there was a story
in the 2000s where Galactus died where
he was allowed to die basically was kind
of like hey look if I died terrible
things will happen and it was allowed to
die or he was allowed to die and then in
turn like basically find out that like
Abraxas this beam that represents
destruction and the multiverse breaks
out of this kind of prison he's always
been in and then he in turn starts
travelling around like the multiverse
killing every version of Galactus that
he finds so again it was it was kind of
crazy it was a pretty wonky story but
suffice it to say a practice is an
abacus is insanely powerful like he's
it's it's nuts how powerful he is but to
take someone like that like Galactus and
then throw him into the the mystic
depths there's no telling what would
happen that's exactly what strange says
and so when he gets in there with all
this magical arms and an armory and so
on and so forth then suddenly he's met
by like this giant stampede of people
who are I guess beings who were all just
fleeing for their lives because Galactus
like the first thing he does is start
consuming like energy off of one of
these planets collide just starts doing
exactly what Galactus is doing now
here's a funny thing strange shows up
here it says hey look man you can't
necessarily do that now the fact that
Galactus addresses him directly is a
little bit of standing and that's kind
of one of the funny things that way
talks about here right because we know
from from Marvel Comics good lot just
never usually addresses just like being
like a normal person he doesn't really
care he's like I mean why would I care
whether I care enough to talk to you you
know one there's nothing you could
probably tell me that would that would
interest me intellectually right I mean
you're no Reed Richards
and to like you're not really powerful
enough to spot me or challenge me so why
do like here but Galactus literally
addresses him and it's like why am I
here so we're just kind of like okay
Galactus is trying to get a feel for
surroundings trying to figure out like
what's going on why he's here all that
kind of good stuff
not only that what's happened is he's
basically been like sent to a particular
place in the in the depths of the mystic
realm and then bound inside of a prison
and so he has like these little small
planetoids here and there but those
aren't enough to do anything for him as
the what he basically does is like break
out of his prison and into like the
greater depths then like the first
person he runs into her the first thing
he runs into is Miss Anna koreff now
Miss Adha gorath is is what's referred
to as the beast of paint but there's no
real history to go on here because this
is the first time he's ever been seen
and then he dies because it's like it's
like okay ah so that guy's gone but what
this is this is actually Mark Waid
proving a very important point
Kosuke actresses a character is largely
assumed he just absorbs a life the the
ambient energies of a life-sustaining
planet and then moves on what this
actually confirms is something that we I
guess maybe I always kind of knew in the
back of our heads but never really
thought about that Galactus can absorb
energy off of beings and that's exactly
what happens here right like this beast
of pain goes to attack Galactus and then
basically shows him like I have a huge
amount of energy stored inside of me and
in turn Galactus absorbs it all out of
them now it could very well just be that
this guy is kind of like a conduit for
magical energy which means like he
actually stores that energy inside of
him as opposed to being like Doctor
Strange where he just reaches out and
touches it and and harnesses it it could
be that way we don't really know but
whatever the basis behind him is all
this energy that he possesses at his
disposal Galactus absorbs it and that's
when Doctor Strange begins to realize
that a very dangerous thing is happening
with Galactus going through and
absorbing all these magical energies
that exists either in planets or in
people inside this universe that what
he's basically doing is tapping into a
source of energy that he's not really
familiar with and that even dr. strange
himself doesn't really know what effect
it'll have right I mean like to what
this is it's like a lot just going out
it's like you going out and eating like
a standard Western diet every day right
like 50% protein 25% fats and like 25%
carbs or something along those lines you
know 30% fats and and you know 20% carbs
or whatever whatever the case says you
going out and and in turn like consuming
a standard Western diet and then just
suddenly jumping into like a random diet
like a like an exotic diet with no
indication of what it'll do to you right
like it's it's the best example I could
think of but that's basically it here is
literally what's going on Galactus is
form is is predicated on consuming
life-sustaining energies in a universe
he was born into so he was born for that
purpose he was not born for the purpose
of consuming magical energy who knows
what kind of situation that's gonna
create so of course dr. strange binds
Galactus and is able to do it for a
pretty good chunk of time but again
we're talking about Galactus so the
concern that he has is I'm not going to
be able to keep this guy bound forever
like eventually he's going to break out
and of course like Galactus begins to
you and then - - binds re-established
again and we're met with the arrival of
Clea now Clea is a character that we
haven't talked about ever and we've
never had a reason to because she's
never she hasn't appeared in a very long
time anyway
the basis behind this really actually
goes into the origin of two beings boom
our
and Dormammu now back to the old strange
tale comics when when Dormammu first
popped up what you got was the the the
origin of his character shortly after
around that time we also learned about a
group called the fall team now the fall
team FAL T I and II this is a group that
existed in another dimension and it was
naturally adept at wielding magical
energy the issue is that Dormammu and
Umar wanted like physical pleasures more
or less and of course that was kind of
banished because they were beings
composed of like spiritual forms and so
because of that they basically ended up
killing a senator I think killing their
their Creator and then in turn they like
were banished to the Dark Dimension now
the dark dimension at the time was ruled
by a guy named King anar he was like a
warlord or something like that anyway
basically like Kumar and Dormammu showed
up in the Dark Dimension and we're kind
of like okay so like this is our place
now and usually like subterfuge and
being deceptive they basically started
to use King anar as a way to essentially
like doom his own people the merch at
least I'm pretty sure that's how it's
pronounced mercs I think it's mhm u u RK
s I think it's how you pronounced or how
you spell it but basically this was a
group that like was a normal inhabitant
of the Dark Dimension
and then in turn could also use magical
energy what ended up happening here is
that with with Dormammu and Umar taking
over and then Dormammu basically going
into his false uniform which is his
energy based form and then umar
maintaining her human form this led to a
more engaging in a affair of sorts with
one of the servants of Dormammu
and this basically led to the birth of
Clea and so Clea is technically the
rightful heir to the throne of the Dark
Dimension ah so think of think of like
katana for mortal kombat basically um
but she's technically the rightful heir
from to that to the Dark Dimension but
she doesn't really take it because door
mom who currently rules it so unless she
was able to master I guess muster a
sizable force that was powerful enough
to take out Dormammu in his own
dimension which is probably never gonna
happen in turn like she would is
basically kind of reside there now
she and dr. strange teamed up a couple
times and then like the second or third
time that happened they fell in love she
became a student of dr. strange and then
eventually he married her she became his
wife so now she's his ex-wife so but
basically just take it as you know his
ex-wife is here in order to help him
which is kind of weird but what they end
up doing is basically saying like what
we need is an alliance of people like we
basically need an alliance of magic
wielders out there some of the most
powerful people in existence in order to
like get rid of Galactus and banished
him from here and so that's when you
bring in omar now umar is synonymous
with the
deception right I mean that's the nature
of her character she's the sister of
Dormammu is one of these things were
like she's always trying to like topple
her brother and take his place or she's
really kind of wants to be second place
and just wants to sort of manipulate
things behind the scenes her schemes and
motivations really never make sense to
anybody but herself and she's insanely
powerful but it's one of the funny
things that we're seeing here is it like
Galactus is more powerful and that's
kind of the cool thing is because what
they're doing is they're they're
literally going through and like they're
like Galactus is kind of being ravaged
by the very energy he's consuming and so
it seems like one of these things where
the more energy consumes the more seems
to consume him now the reality of this
is Doctor Strange looks at that and says
no no it's not really that I mean I
guess he is kind of being consumed book
a lot dis is changing and the reason why
is because Galactus is actually a being
of pure energy that's one of the things
to bear in mind Galactus doesn't really
have a true physical form he did at one
point but when he was born into the main
model universe as Galactus he was born
as a being of pure energy that's why it
is whenever Galactus shows up on the
doorstep of a races planet and he's
gonna consume their planet he's a mirror
to them right so like the scrolls will
see a scroll version of Galactus the
Kree will see a free version of Galactus
but it's the outfit he wears on the fact
that he's there to consume their planet
that makes him so terrifying now of
course we found that out in the trial of
Reed Richards way back in the 1980s
whenever it was that story came out but
the overall gist behind this is that
what's happening is the normal energies
that make up Galactus the energy is of a
positive universe basically like the
main Marvel Universe are slowly being
replaced by these exotic energies he's
consuming right so it's like having a
bottle of water and then dropping some
iodine inside right like some dye have
come some time it's gonna start to
permeate out and then eventually change
the water if you put enough in there and
that's what's happening here Galactus is
essentially being poisoned by magical
energy and so what ended up happening is
dr. strange this is okay fine in this
case like we can't have you running
around and consuming like all these
life-sustaining planets because we have
no idea what effect it's gonna have on
you like in the extreme if you get to
the wrong one so I will do two things
one I will basically become your new
Herald go out and try to find a planet
that is uninhabited and two I will try
to make sure the uninhabited planet I
find will keep you sustained but will
not continue to poison you the way that
like all these other planets have been
consuming you and that's why it's kind
of a crazy thing because Galactus is
just sort of falling apart more or less
and so what is up happening here is you
end up having like Dormammu who's
basically visited like by Mesa hog war F
and it's kind of like hey look like
there's this crazy powerful being who's
consuming everything you have to stop
him and that's we end up finding out
Dormammu is already aware of Galactus
like he's already aware of the power
Galactus has it he's already aware of
like what he's capable of and like he's
already making moves against Galactus to
be able to like defeat him and that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
we're Doctor Strange is sort of hopping
around and going from world to world
trying to find different locations you
have like the forces of Umar who are
traveling around and they actually end
up running up on nightmare now
nightmares actually a cool guy
so in Marvel Comics the way this works
is that whenever you lay down and go to
sleep if you have a nightmare
those nightmares feed the actual
nightmare dimension which powers the guy
nightmare but they're also there's also
a potential that for them to be kind of
fed back to you in the extreme and
that's one of the reasons why nightmares
is really considered to be like an
immortal and indestructible being so
long as beings exist and they can dream
the nightmare can exist because they
will have nightmares the only way to
really to get nightmare to a point where
he can be defeated is to wipe out all
sentient life but you'd have to
essentially blink out the universe which
would kill him anyway
um because you yeah I mean literally
it's it's the dreams of like all beings
in existence and then potentially the
dreams in the future so like or at least
the nightmares of people in the future
it's really weird and it's really
finicky but basically if they got
nightmare on their side well it may not
necessarily be enough to like overpower
Galactus in his entirety and like
destroy him because he's just so amped
up with all this magical power it would
certainly be enough to create like some
havoc and so we're basically Doctor
Strange ends up finally locating a
planet and then grabs Galactus and
brings him back what the end of finding
out is there's all these small little
instances of people getting in their way
of trying to like slow Galactus down and
eventually he ends up having to invoke
his power and sorry attacking these guys
was of course begins to depower him a
little bit more now eventually we end up
finding out - like once they get to this
planet and like villages goes to consume
it immediately right off the bat we end
up finding out something is wrong now
this plan has been tainted and that's
what we end up finding out Dormammu was
the one behind it that Dormammu is the
new Herald of Galactus and that Dormammu
tampered the tamper with this planet so
that when Galactus went to consume it it
would amp him up but it would also twist
him and screw him up and basically
become kind of a servant to Dormammu but
at the same time like Dormammu becoming
a Herald of Galactus the other half of
is that when dr. strange sits down it
says okay so like something else has to
be going on here right like yes Dormammu
is very very powerful but like by
himself at least that seems to be the
indication by himself Dormammu is not
necessarily powerful enough to stop
Galactus now we actually don't know this
we can't really argue either way because
the reality of this is that they've
never met and there are two beings from
two distinctly different dimensions I
mean I guess you can find some way to
kind of you know move the pieces around
and cook the book so that some argument
can be made but the reality is that like
we've never seen this happen before
we've never seen a full-on conflict
between Galactus and Dormammu and so
it's really kind of creating a narrative
and creating a standard and saying okay
so like you know definitively Dormammu
is not more power is no more powerful
than Galactus right like there's these
like largest is more powerful than
normal essentially like that's really
kind of what's being said here and that
the other the other way to kind of
manipulate this the other kind of power
that was needed came from Mephisto as it
always does but basically the gist
behind this is that the alliance that
was formed between Dormammu and Mephisto
that wasn't so basically mean is that
Dormammu would conquer planets a
continue to expand his his reign his
kingdom right like outside of the Dark
Dimension and into other places in the
mystic realms and then like expand his
kingdom but every single world that is
consumed and the people who perished
basically expand Mephisto realm now this
is this is kind of the crazy thing
Mephisto doesn't really take souls in
the traditional sense Mephisto is vers
like his his section of Hell is is
essentially like expanded by people who
sold their souls for some particular
deed right like whether it was money or
like success or power or something along
those lines but they basically bargained
with Mephisto not realized and they're
like when everything was done Mephisto
would take their soul to his realm ah
that's that's really what his version of
hell is Kisan for it's not just everyone
who dies just automatically goes to her
Mephisto is at up presumably it's those
individuals that he probably made pacts
with which he could I mean presumably
Mephisto could use his almost infinite
power to show up and it basically appear
to every single person who's basically
dying on the planet at the same time and
saying like you know I can I can do this
I can basically you know I can save you
all you have to do is say yes and they
say okay like they they basically make a
deal with Mephisto and then when they
all end up dying anyway and they show up
in his realm and he's like you know
they're like well I thought you were
gonna save us and it's like I did I
saved you for my realm you know and then
just BAM leave him there something along
those lines I mean presumably he could
do that and he's almost infinitely
powerful but that's basically what's
going on
- ah
in mephisto are now working in tandem
together and that door mom who is now
the Herald of Galactus taking him from
planet to planet and basically showing
him all the best worlds to feed on
presumably all the worlds of door mama
wants to go after but it's actually
pretty beast like I'm pretty excited
about this like I want to see him fight
that's what I want to see like Galactus
versus Dormammu but would that be said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you